yesterday we witnessed one of the most
stunning and cartoonish implosions of a
public figure during congressional
testimony that I can remember and I have
seen a lot of examples of this I'm
talking about Donald Trump's
propagandizing Attorney General William
bar who testified before Congress before
a Senate committee and imploded in a way
that is really a data point in recent
political history extraordinarily
notable now the entire thing went on for
hours and I'm not going to play hours of
testimony for you and there are actually
lots of clips I could show you a senator
mazie Hirono did very very well some
other senators did very well but just
for today just to take sort of a tour of
one moment of this testimony I'm gonna
focus in on Senator Kamala Harris's
questioning of bar which exposed some
major problems in the building evidence
against Barr as not a law enforcement
official but just as a partisan actor in
this entire Moeller report Fiasco who
should immediately be impeached for his
role in the management of the Moller
investigation and the release of the
report Barr refused to even answer
clearly like it started and it was
already bad Kamala Harris just asking a
yes-or-no question and bar refusing to
answer whether Trump or people around
Trump have directed Barr to investigate
specific people which we're going to get
into in a bit
William Barr admitted that he made the
decision not to charge President Trump
with obstruction without having looked
at the evidence of the investigation
which in and of itself there's some
justification for and I'll talk about
that but it opened the door to Barr
suggesting that maybe part of the
decision not to charge Trump was made by
Rod Rosenstein which is extremely
problematic since Rosenstein was a
witness in that investigation stunning
conflict of interest that Barr admitted
to a witness in an investigation
shouldn't get to decide whether that
investigation leads to charges it's a
total miscarriage of justice and I hate
to have to do this last disclaimer here
but I have to because of the political
environment in which we are finding
ourselves
I'm telling you that Kamala Harris
crushed Barr in this
hearing because she did I'm not
endorsing her for president this is not
an attack on Bernie who I like just skip
it okay if you're gonna write to me and
your reaction to this will be I'm now a
shill for Kamala Harris she crushed bar
and that's what we're talking about here
so check out bar squirming mealy-mouthed
unable to even deny that the White House
is telling him who to investigate and
notice that if you're watching cory
booker is sitting to Kamala Harris is
right the smirk on his face is the smirk
of I am watching something really really
good happen right here here's bar
starting to implode on national
television Thank You mr. chairman
attorney general bar has the president
or anyone at the White House ever asked
or suggested that you open an
investigation of anyone I wouldn't I
wouldn't yes or no has the president or
anyone at the White House ever asked or
suggested that you open an investigation
of anyone yes or no please sir the
president or anybody else seems you
would remember something like that and
be able to tell us yeah but I'm trying
to grapple with the word suggest I mean
there have been discussions of matters
out there that they have not asked me to
open a investigation but perhaps they've
suggested I don't know I wouldn't say
suggest hinted I don't know inferred you
don't know okay yeah the answer that he
doesn't know is stunning and I don't
really get why Kamala Harris moves on at
this point I would have continued on
that but I also get that she had other
things to get to in limited time but
stunning and relevant because there are
suspicions that Trump is pushing the
Justice Department to open
investigations into people involved with
the Moller probe into Hillary Clinton
Hillary Clinton associates who knows and
barred doesn't deny it here already
extraordinary and the look on Cory
Booker's face that smirk really says it
all so let's continue and this is really
key Kamala Harris gets to a really
important point Barr and Rosen's
put out a statement saying that the
evidence led them to decide not to
charge Donald Trump with obstruction but
Kamala Harris wants to know did you
actually look at the evidence and the
answer is of course no March 24th
summary you wrote that quote after
reviewing the special counsels final
report Deputy Attorney General
Rosenstein and I have concluded that the
evidence is not sufficient to establish
that the president committed an
obstruction of justice offense now the
special counsels investigation produced
a great deal of evidence I've led to
believe it included witnesses notes and
emails witnesses congressional testimony
witnesses interviews which were
summarized in the FBI 302 forms former
FBI director Comey's memos and the
president's public statements my
question is in reaching your conclusion
did you personally review all of the
underlying evidence no we took an
accepted did we accepted mr. Rosen sign
no we accepted the statements in the
report as the factual record we did not
go underneath it to see whether or not
they were accurate we accepted it as
accurate and made our say you are
accepted the report as the evidence yes
you did not question or look at the
underlying evidence that supports the
conclusions in the report no so let's
talk about this think back for a second
to when the bar letter was released the
report was sent to bar and within 48
hours Barr was able to say we're not
indicted on a gnat the time we said how
did he decide so quickly and Trumpets
wrote to me and said well David
obviously William bar got the report way
in advance and had time to look at all
the underlying evidence in that report
and here is William Barr himself saying
actually no he didn't look at the
evidence before deciding not to
prosecute he did it based on the Muller
report which actually says there is
substantial evidence of obstruction so I
want to be really careful here okay
because some law enforcement officials
reached out to me because I talked about
this on my live stream last night and
said David hold on a second it's not
crazy for Barr not to look at the
underlying evidence in that
as Rob for example wrote to me imagine a
murder investigation where somebody got
shot the report says the shooters
fingerprints were on the gun the
Attorney General wouldn't necessarily go
to evidence and look at the fingerprints
themselves they would just assume
because this is how things work that the
report claiming the fingerprints were
found is good enough and that's a
perfectly reasonable point but there's a
couple caveats here that you have to
think about number one the report said
there is substantial evidence of
obstruction so when William Barr says I
didn't actually look at the evidence to
make that decision well the report said
there was substantial evidence so when
you don't go and look at the evidence
for yourself and you make a decision
that seems to run directly counter to
what was contained in the report that
starts to be problematic but then
there's another kind of issue here which
is the whole point is Muller didn't say
that he recommends or can exonerate
Trump from charges on obstruction
normally when an Ag or a state's
attorney prosecutor whatever get a
report the report says on the basis of
the evidence here's our recommendation
as to what you should do indict or not
indict this was left up to bars so the
standard is different with regard to
bars responsibility to look at to
actually look at the evidence now this
is all just a lead-up because this gets
us to Kamala Harris saying isn't it a
problem that you made a decision about
charging the president or not charging
the president without looking at the
evidence and bar tries to play this game
of well go ask Bob Muller because in the
end he's the prosecutor I'm just the
Attorney General at which point Kamala
Harris says well you did make the
decision not Muller right and bar gets
visibly confused and it becomes unclear
who actually made this decision and it
is barred digging the hole deeper he
ties himself up into a pretzel and then
big mistake he mentions will actually
rod Rosenstein was involved in this
decision which we'll get to in a second
take a look as the Attorney General of
the United States
you run the United States Department of
Justice if in any US Attorney's Office
around the country the head of that
office
when being asked to make a critical
decision about in this case the person
who holds the highest office in a land
and whether or not that person committed
a crime would you accept them
recommending a charging decision to you
if they'd had not reviewed the evidence
well that's a question for Bob Muller
he's the US attorney he's the one who
presents the report but it was you who
made the charging decision sir you made
the decision not to charge the president
in the process memo and in the
declination memo you said it was your
baby what did you mean by that it was my
baby to look to let to decide whether or
not to disclose it to the public and
whose decision was it who had the power
to make the decision about whether or
not the evidence was sufficient probably
make a determination of whether there
had been an obstruction of justice
prosecution memos go up to the
supervisor in this case it was the
attack you know the Attorney General and
the Deputy Attorney General who decide
on the final decision what does is mean
what is language how does English work
I'm so confused how did I get here and
there he said it he talks about the
Deputy Attorney General so bar opens the
door to rod Rosenstein which Kamala
Harris gets to and this is the key
moment okay and you're going to be
confused about what William bar says in
this next clip because it doesn't make
any sense
did rod Rosenstein decide on prosecuting
or not prosecuting trump on obstruction
of justice and if he did Rosenstein was
a witness in that probe why is a witness
in the probe deciding about whether
there will or will not be prosecutions
was he cleared to be making those
decisions asked Kamala Harris and
William bar says I don't know I suppose
he was cleared or maybe not this is what
a liar looks like be the conflict you
know I haven't been the only
decision-maker here now let's take the
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosen Stein
who was approved by this Senate 94 to
six with specific discussion on the
floor that he would be responsible for
supervising the Russian investing I'm
glad you brought up that that's a great
our heirs experience and we have
a number of senior prosecutors in the
department involved in this process both
career and non-career yes I have another
question and I'm glad you brought that
subject up because I have a question
about that earlier today in response to
Senator Graham you said quote that you
consulted with Rosenstein constantly
unquote with respect to the special
counsels investigation report but Deputy
Attorney General Rosenstein is also a
key witness in the firing of FBI
director Comey did you consult that's
with D I'm not finished did you consult
with DOJ ethics officials before you
enlisted rod Rosenstein to participate
in a charging decision for an
investigation the subject of which he is
also a witness my understanding was that
he had been cleared already to
participate in it but so you had
consulted with them and they cleared it
no I think they cleared it when he when
he took over the investigation did you
can I understanding I am you don't know
whether he's been cleared of a conflict
of interest he would be participating if
there was a conflict of interest so
you're saying that it did not need to be
reviewed by the career ethics officials
in your office I believe I believe it
was well I believe it was reviewed and I
and what we also point out this seems to
be a bit of a flip flop because when the
president supporters were checking that
you're not answering the question
directly did the ethics officials in
your office in the Department of Justice
review the appropriateness of rod
Rosenstein being a part of making a
charging decision on an investigation
which he is also a witness in yeah Mike
so as I said my understanding was he had
been cleared and he had been cleared
before I arrived endlessly endlessly
stunning this is what a liar looks like
bars a hatchet man he did what he was
brought in to do it's very clear now and
he has to be removed let me know what
you think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
I want to hear from you about this